هل هناك اي تشابه تراه بين هذه الازمه
التي يعيش العالم حاليا مع ازماتها
السابقه ام ان هذه المره فعلا هو في تدخل
غير حذر في السياسات النقديه العالميه
يؤدي الى تعقيد الوضع اكثر من الازمات
السابقه التي مرت على العالم
2008 و2 2011 يعني خاصه على الارتفاع بعض
الاسعار المولد الاوليه والمده والحجملها
ولكن التحليل الاعمق يقول ان هذه الازمه
مختلفه كثيرا على سابقاتها هذه ليست بازمن
هذه ليست بازمه همم
بعض المواد همم وليس غيرها وكذلك همم
المناخ كله والسياق كل هذه الاسماء هو
مختلف جدا يعني همم يعني بعد الكوفيد الى
حد
والحرب في في في اوكرانيا وتع- تداعياتها
الارتفاع الاسعار ابتداء من قبل الحرب في
همم في في في اوكرانيا شوفنا كذلك العديد
من الدول والمديونيه لعديد من الدول
ارتفعت بنسبه كبيره نعرف لما هي في العديد
من الدول يعني ايه
الزياده في الاجور ما تدخل فيه دوامات همم
اخرى ثانيه نطاق العالمي كله كازمه مختلفه
ال- اا السياق مختلف وكذلك حتى النظام
معالي الوزير بانه جذور الازمه همم لا
علاقه لها كثيرا بالنظام المالي العالمي
همم وان الحروب والازمات الصحيه كبد
نايتين وما زلنا نعاني منه حتى الان همم
كان له التاثير الاكبر يعني الامر يتعلق
بمشكله هيكليه في النظام المالي والاقتصاد
العالمي لعدم القدره على مواجهه هذه
المصائب او الكوارث
هي الازمات الحاليه حسب راينا كشفت
العديد من النقائس
والحدود النظام الاقتصادي والمالي العالمي
كنا نعرف ولم ناخذ كل الدروس من ازمه 2008
للاسف والان اصبحنا في نهايه حصرنا نهايه
مرحله كانه قوس كبير ابتدا تقريبا من 300
سنه والان نحن في في مرحله تغيير هذا
النظام يعني توازنات كبيره جديده في
العالم ونظام جديد ولابد ان يكون هناك
نظام جديد في اكثر عداله واكثر مساواه
يعني
تقريبا فما عشرات الاشخاص في العالم
يمتلكون مثل ما يمتلك نصف البشريه